so they left California they don't want
to be in California but I think the
Texas humidity was something that was
really hard to live with cuz they they
they just looked at the politics and the
politics is dope I love that there's
more freedom here what but then they're
like holy [__] the summers are really
crazy and then like the mosquitoes are
insane sounds like a California we are
weather wimps dude we are we got it so
good yeah so when you go anywhere else
that has a little bit of a harsh
condition you're like it's extreme
that's crazy but dude
[Music]
like
so Bart you always talk about Sir people
leaving
California [__] I'm about to fact
check your [__] ass
yeah so according to uh South Bay uh
news from cbsnews.com no one ever heard
of them before but it's okay California
is seeing a sizable influx of new
residents relocating from Texas makes
sense why doesn't that just sound like
like people from California that moved
to Texas are coming back that's what it
sounds like to me oh cuz they're like
man Texas is ass you know there's they
just they just did a a survey on the
three like biggest cities of people
moving to the first one's Sacramento
really yeah and then the second one or
third one's Vegas and then like the
other one's Texas yeah and Sacramento is
all the people leaving San Francisco cuz
they're getting priced out so they're
like and we can work remote so what's
the next closest city Sacramento I
thought that California saw the biggest
like within the past 3 years straight of
people leaving the state they did y okay
I think over half a million people left
wow but this is saying that they're
coming back or just saying people are
just moving from Texas in general so let
me just get into to the data okay so for
for more than a decade The so-call Great
California Exodus has seen residents
leave the state and droves mostly
because of the High Cost of Living yeah
for more than a decade the pandemic
obviously made it worse basically
created a focal point where everyone was
like I got to just make a decision now
right yeah so then hundreds of thousands
of people leave to places like
Washington State Idaho Idaho yeah
Florida Montana was one everywhere else
Utah everywhere dude literally
everywhere everywhere anywhere that's
cheaper which is everywhere yeah but
then there are many people who are
actually bucking that Trend making their
way to the Bay Area from other states
and that's one reason why one woman they
interviewed called Allison halice she
said she was excited to move her family
to California cuz the
weather which is that's true the weather
is amazing it's amazing can't which has
made her daily walks with her dog
whiskey much more enjoyable than
previously right she said I wanted to
take him on daily walks she said I love
seeing all the tents and all the
encampments she didn't say that and and
the nice weather that's what she said
you can actually see it yeah the San
Francisco [__] no you're colluding
that's collusion all the cracked out the
I love stepping in poop and big poops
andig medium poops diarrhea poops yeah
I'm fine with it she's like as long as
they poops I'm I'm stepping in it and
I'm happy it's pretty cool that Target
doesn't charge you for anything grab
whatever you want leave take whatever
you want yeah she's well she likes it
when she goes to Target and then
everything's behind glass and then if
she wants something they smash her
against glass like a hockey player and
they're like are you going to [__]
pay for
it that's what she said a quote that's
customer service baby damn she said it's
gorgeous scenery the weather is so nice
nice yeah and she got a job at a tech
company in San Jose so she doesn't have
to deal with the reality oh she's really
s does she does she like the uh takes an
hour to go like 2 miles she doesn't like
it she loves it she loves it oh she
loves cuz she gets to listen to our
podcast I heard that California had like
a
major I guess like what do you call it
flood no no um what do you call it when
people come in immigration influx but
it's within citizens influx right influx
in the 19 like mid 1950s mhm cuz you
know that song like California Dreaming
and all that [__] right like I guess
people would vacation to California from
other states and they go this is [__]
nice like we should move here and then a
lot of people came and drove and started
like moving into
California wasn't there also like that
that hippie 60s movement too where
that's NorCal yeah and that's because of
our think was like starting to change
the whole like Progressive well in the
record this is yeah this is the only
time that there's been a like people
leaving so it's always been people
coming in yeah and then now people are
leaving cuz they're like oh this CL we
never been on the negative side until
now so you think California is over do
you think it's no I think it's it goes
in waves it's like oh it's good now it's
bad then later it's going to be good
again I kind of feel like California
feels like it's too big to fail so like
even though Elon left Toyota left like a
lot of these industries are leaving like
it still has a huge G GDP just as a
state so like a lot of things still keep
it really strong cuz there's the
entertainment industry which is kind of
dwindling but it's still a lot of money
it's like oh boohoo it's like less
billions but it's still a lot right and
then you have um Tech you have a farming
that's a really big one that's probably
not going to go so it's just I think if
you look at the state G GDP it's like
top 10 in the world so it could be its
own country yeah I think the scary part
so it does produce a lot but the scary
part is even though it produces a lot
cost a living well no California
technically is broke so even though they
make a [__] ton of money they have no
money so the only way they can they can
only uh get money is to tax its citizens
or borrow so it feels like a choke on
the citizens and all the burden is like
high sales tax High property tax High
income tax so it's like citizens are
getting [__] squished down because
they mismanage the money they have gas
tax which is kind of cool that's really
cool actually I [__] I was getting
gas for like $3 something in Vegas the
other day I filled up my truck with like
60 bucks there's random gas stations
with the craziest prices like that dude
my dad was here cuz for cuz Thanksgiving
and when I was paying for Thanksgiving
food he was like this is so cheap he's
like I can't believe how cheap this is
like milk's a dollar off like a bunch
little things are just did you know that
um so I would think that San Francisco
was the most expensive city but they did
a survey in San Diego one of these areas
in San Diego was the most expensive not
I don't think it's the main it's like a
city in in San Diego's County that's
where my folks are San Diego but the
reasoning is it's housing it's groceries
it's just everyday everything the whole
cost of living cuz like maybe San
Francisco is just the housing and then
like you can find cheap Beats or
whatever right but that's it's like
everything put together it's like hell
expensive yeah so California is still
seeing a net loss of re residents per
year to Texas but the trend is kind of
reversing like as far as the amount of
Texans coming to California it's
increasing a little bit I wonder if
they're true Texans or just Californians
that are moving back I think
California's moving I met a couple of
them uh they said they moved during the
pandemic they're the ones that actually
end up moving to Vegas so they left
California they don't want to be in
California but I think the Texas
humidity was something that was really
hard to live with cuz they they they
just looked at the politics and the
politics is dope I love that there's
more freedom here whatever whatever but
then they're like holy [__] the summers
are really crazy and then like the
mosquitos are insane sounds like a
California we are weather Wims dude we
are we got it so good yeah WEA [__]
so when you go anywhere else that has a
little bit of a harsh condition you're
like it's extreme that's crazy but dude
like I don't know how they do it cuz to
me I bought a place so it's like I'm
stuck I am not I a rider for Vegas now
dude I don't care if it's if there's a
[__] tornado next to my house I
bought a house here like this is how it
is I'm not going to [__] leave
because this is how it is you could sell
and move somewhere else just like how
you did from California to Vegas but
Vegas doesn't really have natural
disasters I think it's just like super
wind really [__] hot and dry but dude
it's windy as [__] yeah it gets really
windy wouldn't that be really funny yeah
but you got a four walls to protect you
yeah wouldn't that be funny if all the
people coming from Texas are just the
illegal people that jump the border at
the bottom
and that's been the plan hey look at all
these guys oh Texas coming back come on
do you well why do you think they're
coming back knowing that it's still
expensive is it really just the weather
I actually people who can afford it I
think will just go back they'll bounce
back I I actually think like most people
miss their family and friends because I
don't really think it's like California
and the taxes and all that I think like
moving out's probably cool in the
beginning but then you really feel it
when you don't have your support network
when you don't have your normal like
things that you're used to getting and
whatever and I think that's the biggest
thing is like it's hard to make friends
as an adult and it's hard to make like
new groups and you know all that stuff
especially cuz everyone's busy and they
already have their groups and I and I
noticed that the most from people that
are like moving to different states I
had uh I always love to interview my my
Uber drivers or lift drivers when I come
back to Cali just to see like lay of the
land like what are people going through
and [__] and this lady was telling me
yesterday she's like I and it's the same
stories every time it's like I can
barely get by I have I have I have to do
like three jobs to even afford they just
want you to tip more probably probably s
they make more money than you no but but
then she was telling me she's Cuban
she's like I'm Cuban and like my family
came here from communism and she's like
this this is the start of what communism
was in Cuba according to her parents and
I hate hearing that I know it scares
[__] out of me that scares me yeah
according to her own parents she's like
if my dad was alive right now she's like
I'm glad my dad is dead because if he
was alive right now it would kill him oh
yeah I hate hearing that that comparison
is very popular from people isn't it
crazy how a lot of people who ran away
from communist countries they know the
warning signs and they're like you guys
got to stop and then no one listens to
them no dude she was telling me she's
like think about it like this she's like
we just raised a whole generation of
kids when to know or believe that if the
government tells you you have to stay in
your home you do and it's normal whereas
like she's like my generation she's like
you talk to Cuban people she's like we
were no way [__] you you you can't keep
me in my house actually I know what my
rights are but they're not teaching
these kids their rights and I was like
damn that's deep [__] so was she
protesting and and she was saying she
wasn't complying with any of it she said
I never stayed inside I always did my
own [__] feel gets even worse because
here the the the government didn't even
need to do it after a while other people
did it for that oh yeah dude I had
haters in my DMs like saying you're the
reason why like people are dying and all
that [__] and it's because I was filming
like I was at my friend's farm and I was
in the back of a pickup truck and I was
vlogging outside outside with no mask on
at a farm in a [__]
Farm to Grandma's everywhere yeah
literally and then that's the reason why
I'm you know I'm [__] spreader number
one dude so she told me she's like in
Cuba they have snitches on every
neighborhood in every neighborhood there
snitches and they're they're supposed to
make sure that you're compliant with
whatever the government is saying to do
and if they hear any if the snitch hears
that you're not complying or like if you
have an item in your house she said they
they would come into the into her house
and they would make sure that they have
damn all their items nothing Contraband
like nothing that they're not supposed
to have so she said that she said that
her Mom hated the Communists so much
that when they were on their way to like
to immigrate to America the Communists
were so pissed that she that they were
able she was like getting a visa from
America to leave that they ended up um
her mom would take the pressure cooker
that they had and she would put it over
the fence cuz it actually worked every
day she would put it over the fence so
that when they came into her house to
catalog all the items in her home they
would never know she had this pressure
cooker just so they couldn't have it
when she left and she gave it to her
[__] W it's crazy [__] damn they
catalog your items yeah they catalog all
your items every day yeah and she said
that they and like she like I was saying
the snitches so she had a snitch right
snitch [__] one of so she said that her
her daughter would wear the same pair of
shoes every day because you only get
issued like a pair of shoes and if you
want to to get a new pair of shoes you
have to get like a basically a ticket
from the school principal that says I
can go get a pair of shoes now and then
you take it to a store and then you hope
that the store has those shoes because
you're in communism and then she's like
yeah so she's like my daughter um we
kept on resoling her shoes and they got
the leather got so bad that I went to
the principal and I was like can can I
please get a ticket so that I can get my
daughter shoes and the principal said
have your daughter go to school for a
week Barefoot and then I'll consider
giving you a ticket and she said like
hell I'll screw you like I my daughter
is not going to school Barefoot I have
pride and that's my daughter so then she
said she pulled her daughter out of
school and if in communist cubba she
said if you um if your kid doesn't go to
school for 3 days that um somebody in
your area is supposed to report that
your kid didn't go to school right so
the principal tells the snitch in her
neighborhood hey she didn't come to
school and then the snitch happened to
be getting helped by her mother right
her mother was the only person in her
neighborhood Who Could inject um the the
snitch's mom with like a certain thing
to keep her alive and she kept on she
did it three times a day so she said the
snitch in a corrupt way wouldn't tell on
on her because then she'd be screwed and
then he'd be screwed right corruption to
her benefit yeah yeah yeah but most of
those corrupt countries you have to play
different corrupting like to to go
around it yeah but who wants to live
like that right that's that's why
everybody's like do you think California
is ever going to get to a level where
people like the government has that much
control over your life I don't know
because we still operate under heavy
Commerce like those kind of com
communist countries like they don't op
they don't have Goods in services that
we do right so at the end of the day
like it will be a different form because
they still need the Sheep to buy and
consume so like it wouldn't get to that
point because a lot of companies and
factories and whatever like they America
in general operate on that what I think
it will be is they already did a good
job during Co killing mom and pop yeah
it'll just be corporate it'll be
corporate oligarchy centralized power
it's I think they will but it's covert
it's just like how Gavin new is the only
person who uh did a mandate so children
had to take the vaccine no other state
did that yeah and but then we didn't
even see it like that we were just like
okay I mean it's already that bad just
one more thing but then people were for
that Y and he had pride in that and then
rescinded it and then now it's like
children shouldn't they don't need it to
be healthy it's like it's and even right
now in Canada I think they can't see
anyone else's news now like if you go on
Instagram or whatever they could only
see because they have the censorship law
so they could only see Canada Outlet
news so you're like oh I want to see
with the American perspective or with
the UK perspective you'll go and just
kind of like how you when you're in
another country and you're trying to
watch Netflix you're like oh your
Netflix doesn't operate here it's like
that you cannot view this news here so
they're only getting Canada fed news
yeah which is
cuz it's harmful the The Independent
Media was harmful up there they they
determined which is happening in Ireland
right now after the firebombing right M
you guys heard about that we haven't
seen each other for two months no I
haven't seen that one but the um they
they basically they ended up um a bunch
of Irish U people and there's a there
was a stabbing right this this guy like
stabs a young girl and he happened to be
a migrant who who came into Ireland and
then all the Irish people basically
firebomb this hotel where a lot of those
migrants were at and the government was
like this is a hate act so now we have
to basically fil filter all the
information that everyone's getting in
Ireland and there's a huge centralized
power grab for that information Canada
style what you're talking about I heard
that um when there was a issue with like
just flooding in a lot of the migrants
in the Scandinavian country I forgot
which one it was but it was like they
didn't do a good job of checking like
who they were what their paperwork is if
they were criminals or cons or whatever
and then so they just let them loose and
then they were going out there
committing crimes robbery rape whatever
but the country was trying to keep it sh
right so anyone that like reported it or
talked about it they were actually
considered racists right so then they
shut shut them down cuz they they were
just like okay how do we fix this cuz
they were like we didn't do a good job
but we can't look stupid right so it's
kind of wild where like they rather let
a serial killer on the loose and tell
everybody be quiet rather than like hey
guys there's a serer killer on the loose
you guys you guys need to go out there
and [__] fix it cuz they don't want
to look incompetent right yeah they
don't want it Trac back to them and oh
why didn't you vet this guy it's not to
say migrants are all like and murderers
and Killers but it's just like if the
government didn't do a good job of
filtering and processing and they just
let any [__] person in they don't
want to take accountability the migrants
themselves are also at risk from that
individual living in what typically
happens in every single like Refugee
situation we saw it with like the
Vietnamese immigrants and everybody the
criminals pre upon the their group like
it always happens well and they pray
upon the good hearts of of of good
nature people yeah like woki
mamas woki mam I'm just kidding news
careful boys is a brand just kidding
news is the man of smart people the
people of just kiding news careful boys
they are very smart just kidding news
the number one podcast in the
world